[Musik]
seit dem 2 juli 1999 beteiligt sich
österreich an der kosovo force kurz
davor der nato ziele der mission sind
der wiederaufbau der region und
infrastruktur sowie die
friedenssicherung durch die geografische
nähe hat österreich ein besonderes
interesse an frieden und sicherheit am
ball kam
die österreichische soldaten sind den
gesamten kosovo eingesetzt derzeit
versehen rund 400 soldatinnen und
soldaten des österreichischen
bundesheeres aus allen bundesländern die
in ihren dienst
ein wichtiges element von k vor sind die
sogenannten eu die teams juli steht für
explosiv portman zinspause die
österreichischen kampfmittelbeseitiger
sorgen unter anderem mit hilfe der
sprengstoffspürhunde für die sicherheit
der bevölkerung und der soldaten im
kosovo wer die militär hundeführer seien
vom edith ihm angefordert worden weil
bei einer fahrzeugkontrolle die türen
geöffnet worden und ein verdächtiges
paket gefunden wurde
in diesen einsatz mit den hunden können
wir auf entfernung die hunde lenken
also das heißt es ihr die team- und wer
militär hundeführer waren entdeckung
dann haben wir den sprengstoff spürhund
nach vorne geschickt er hat dieses paket
gefunden und angezeigt dadurch braucht
sie das team nicht mehr so viel in
gefahr bringen haben den roboter nach
vorne geschickt
[Musik]
dieses paket wurde beseitigt
sie willens military cooperation kurz
sie mich ist die zusammenarbeit ja
kfor-soldaten mit zivilen organisationen
die aufgabe da ziemlich gruppe ist zum
zwecke des truppen schutzes die
durchführung von ziemlich projekten
gemäß der anweisung des national
kontinent commanders der nationalen
führung das ziel ist es der bevölkerung
des kosovo zu zeigen dass wir uns um
ihre nöte und sorgen kümmern mit dem
hintergedanken man schießt nicht auf
jene leute die einem helfen die ziemlich
projekte dienen unter anderem der
überwindung ethnischer grenzen und dem
wirtschafts aufbau des landes bis dato
konnten so zwölf schulen generalsaniert
und zum teil neu gebaut werden
so wurde platz für 5000 schüler
geschaffen in page im nordwesten des
kosovo finden sich zwei österreichische
infanterie kompanien ihre
einsatzbereitschaft und die
internationale zusammenarbeit von land
und luft elementen hierzu oft als
möglich geübt meine funktion herum und
gemeinsames kompaniekommandant talfahrt
ich führe als eine von zwei
österreichischen infanterie kompanien
hier in patch stationiert um eine
gesamtstärke von 110 soldaten die
aufgabe der zebra bedeutet dass man der
menschenmenge beziehungsweise
ausschreitungen und dementsprechend so
kontrolliert dass das dann wirklich
behindert wird
wie klappt die zusammenarbeit mit der
natur ist ein sehr wichtiger faktor weil
er eben stärke demonstriert und bedeutet
dann eben schnell wieder für meine
funktion ist busfahrer und ich
verstärker befehl die sperrkette
konzerte ich habe schon einige
führerscheine mit größeren fahrzeugen
deshalb natürlich mal nicht so schwer
mit dem konto zu fahren das ist mein
erster richtiger ansatz
ich habe den reihen unserer übungen in
deutschland als schütze bin ich
natürlich auch von der band urbesetzung
natürlich hauptaufgabe ist in jedem hat
zb wache und quattro lehnte charlie und
patrouillen aufgabe natürlich im
gesamten kosovo und machten es die im
camp die herausforderung ist es dass
sich durch das jeder mensch individuell
ist muss man natürlich auch die
persönliche einstellung von dem auch
eingehen der eine ist jetzt mehr
überfordert andere unterfordert und da
muss man das korrekt anpassen dass sie
eben die aufträge und alles richtig
machen
aufbauend auf die ausbildung im inland
der erweiterten erste hilfe führen wir
hier im einsatzraum diese ausbildung
natürlich weiter fort mit unterstützung
der amerikanischen monats maschinen
die besondere herausforderung bei dieser
übung ist sicherlich die koordinierung
wir sind hier im internationalen verbund
das heißt ab kompanie ebene ist die
arbeitssprache englisch gemacht wurden
ist jetzt stellvertretender kommandant
der insgesamt rund 4.000 kfor soldaten
aus 28 nationen ist ein auslands
erfahrener österreichische offiziere die
reinhard bock und stuhl
2001 war der vereinten nationalen
funktion pop zwar hier im hauptquartier
gearbeitet
im operation center was mir möglich sagt
das irgendwie saison zum damaligen
zeitung dass er kunden endlich in die
ganze situation bekommen wird und jetzt
bin ja dann einseitig internationalen
position ist in wirklichkeit bin hier
für alle 28 teilnehmenden nationen
verantwortlich
der tag endet meistens relativ spät weil
fast immer abendtermine auch ganz
einfach ein programm stehen das heißt es
kontakt mit den internationalen
organisationen un eu usa für die
praktisch nicht der erste
ansprechpartner denn der einsatz macht
für die österreicher zu weihnachten
nicht pause auch während der festtage
finden batterien oder entschärfungen
sowie übungen statt
trotzdem bleibt zeit für einige
besinnliche stunden
[Musik]